now in Motors uh new cars with muscle
luxury and water vapor yes water vapor
Toyota unveiled its brand new fuel cell
car it's called the marai which means
future in Japanese hydrogen goes in
water vapor comes out so no CO2
emissions price tag around
$63,000 Ford is also out with a new
Twist on an old model the ad on YouTube
speaks for itself
my name is Carol Shelby and performance
is my
business what better way to live up to
his legacy by us doing that Shelby GT
350 through
Ford very modern new Mustang taken to a
whole another
level and the noise they make it's just
delicious delicious okay delicious never
heard that descri Des cried as a car
before but we'll take that Ford unveiled
its new Shelby Mustang GT350 yesterday
the muscle car is powered by a 5.2 L V8
engine it produces over 500 horsepower
now it is not as powerful as the GT500
which has 640 horsepower